[Music]
foreign
here in this video we are going to rank
the most powerful Transformers that will
be appearing in Rise of the bees based
on their Canon lore and what they are
most probably capable of doing in the
upcoming movie we will not include
Unicron on this list since he is already
the most powerful and there is no
competition to him so let's get to it at
17 we have Frieza these are seen in
massive numbers in the trailer as part
of the Terracon army they fight under
the command of scourge and Unicron
Frieza looks like frenzy from the
bathers kind of skeletal in appearance
they are however fast and agile but
their small size as well as being the
cannon for the Infantry they rank at the
bottom of this list at 16 we have the
unnamed Terracon so at first glance one
might think that there are only two
types of terracons the freezer Varian
and the pretty con scorpinox but if you
look closely at the battle in the final
scenes of the trailer you would see that
there is a bigger Terror gun robot
bigger than Frieza and having a similar
design but they are still weak and
fragile
at 15 we have scorpionov while in the
Beavers scorpion is one of the first
Decepticons to be seen and was a unique
specimen in the rise of the bees however
at least in the trailer they are seen in
Mars as a part of the protocols that
work alongside the terracons so by their
numbers it means that they are like
infantry troops but since they are not
as many and are bigger than the Frieza
and unnamed terracons they will rank
above them in power
at 14 we have wheel Jack in the Beavers
movies Wheeljack is portrayed as a
little robot Einstein but in Rise of the
bees he is a bigger Transformer and one
of the autobot's finest scientists he
was shown walking with the other
Autobots including Prime and Aussie in a
trailer and since he isn't really a
fighter but more on the sidelines on the
support role he wouldn't be counted as
one of the powerful ones at 13 we have
RC a Nimble and deadly fighter and
although she was never the toughest or
the biggest of the Autobots she is still
a tough addition to the team because she
is small agile Nimble and packs a
powerful punch she often morphs into a
sports bike most notably a Ducati
Superbike as they always say size does
matter and so that's why she's only at
the 13th spot
number 12 Stratosphere this large unit
is used by the Autobots when they need
to go someplace quickly his cargo plane
mode can fly a complete Squad halfway
across the world and then provide high
altitude cover fire when they arrive so
even though he has the aerial Advantage
he still lacks position that can really
kill another Transformer and also in his
robot mode he is said to be slow and
clumsy
number 11 Mirage Mirage is an Autobot
with extensive infiltration talents he
was first shown transforming into a red
Ferrari 485 however in Rise of the bees
he will transform into a silver Porsche
964 with a blue stripe down the middle
he will be seen with great abilities
that gives credit to his name Mirage
with one of them being able to create
hologram clones to confuse both humans
and the Enemy Number 10 Transit this is
another member of the terracons that
will be seen in the movie he is going to
be a tough nut to crack although Transit
is classified as a Terracon he still has
that conspicuous Decepticon Insignia on
his forehead it is presently unknown
what this signifies for transit or any
other links between the factions but
battle trap another Terracon features a
similar Oddity so there might be a tie
up of both these bad robots working on
the Unicron
number nine Bumblebee Bumblebee is and
always have been one of the smaller
members of the Autobots while his
stature allows him to perform his duties
better than most Autobots because he is
Nimble he is still self-conscious about
his size and for good reason the enemies
are ruthless and almost always bigger
than him he is still a good fighter
though Nimble and very tactical making
use of the environment to his advantage
number eight chidor he is a maximal who
can turn into a huge cheetah in both
bees and robot modes he has an effective
killing machine hitting hard and fast
with exceptional reflexes he was known
to boldly challenge Predacons with his
laser-powered Quasar weapons cheetor and
Bumblebee both are scouts and also the
Guardians of their human friends which
they have a close bond to however in the
movie we do not know if cheetah will
have human companionship
number 7 Knight's bird this was in the
original features a robotic Ninja
Warrior created by Dr Fujiyama
supposedly to show how advanced human
technology had become however in the
movie she will be a true ass kicking
machine it is unknown what or if she is
capable of transformation but she is
seen to be able to fly and will no doubt
have an aerial battle against air razor
and yeah at number six we have a razor
so air razor who possesses the flying
alternative form of a massive Eagle acts
as the maximals Recon serverless member
as well as their heart and soul she is
both gone and assured as well as Brave
and adventurous her ability to fly
alongside her Keen eyesight senses and a
Steady Aim makes her force to be
reckoned with and as we see in the
trailer she might have saved Bumblebee
from scourge
number 5 battle trap so he will be one
of the movie's main villains working
alongside Scourge as one of his
lieutenants battle trap was originally a
part of scopenov's army of Decepticons
on Cybertron in vehicle mode battle trap
transforms into a yellow orange GMC tow
truck in truth he is a Decepticon not a
Terracon but in Rise of the bees he is
classified as the latter as one of
scores subordinates he would play a
significant role in the upcoming movie
number four rhinox he is the Maximus
brute strength and he is in the guise of
a gigantic rhinoceros his double and
triple steel-plated skin protects him
from most injuries including double
barrel laser weapons as well as other
massage and ballistics he has even
beaten Megatron to a halt in past
meetings and clashes without breaking a
sweat so it's not a wild guess that he
will be truly powerful in this upcoming
flick as well
number three Optimus primal so Optimus
primal is the leader of the maximals and
also the captain of the spaceship called
axelon his beast mode is a giant
silverback gorilla he is extraordinary
for not only being able to distinguish
himself despite living in the shadow of
Optimus Prime but he may have even
surpassed the greatest of the Autobots
but in Rise of the bees he seems to be
following prime or at least be working
with him as his equal in an alliance
against the terracons
number two Optimus Prime Prime is shown
in his full red blue and chrome
magnificence morphing into a freight
line in 1987 truck in this movie he is
the leader of the Autobots and one of
the most powerful Transformers ever in
all timelines and continuities in this
timeline he leads the remnants of the
Autobots that escaped Cybertron after
the Great War Prime is agile and also
possesses deadly weapons as well as a
tactical mine therefore Standing Tall
here on the number two spot
and number one Scourge surprisingly
Scourge one of the deadliest of the
terracons and empowered by Unicron as
his Herald is the main antagonist in the
upcoming movie Scourge is a ruthless
tracker and a hunter Unicron himself
built him from the remnants of death
Decepticons he is now on the prowl
controlling the terracons on Earth and
due to being unicron's second income man
he will no doubt be more powerful than
even prime and would need a combined
effort by numerous Autobots or even
Maximus to be taken down
so those are the 17 most powerful
Transformers in Rise of the bees a
release all of them ranked in power so I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hear the like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam